c'est ce qu'on appelle un moment
inattendu alors que depuis plusieurs
semaines l'elysée nous annonce qu
emmanuel macron va prendre la parole
avant finalement d'annuler à deux
reprises voilà qui a soir le président
de la république était donc direct sur
tf1
alors que personne ne l'attendait
bonsoir monsieur le président c'est lors
d'une séquence en direct et en duplex du
palais de l'elysée que le chef de l'état
s'est exprimé sur la situation sanitaire
notamment sur la politique de
vaccination d'ici à la fin de l'été nous
aurons proposé à tous les français
adultes qui le souhaitent un vaccin
le président de la république est aussi
revenu sur le bassin astrazeneca qui
sera réservé au moins de 65 ans comme le
recommande la haute autorité de santé en
fonction de l'âge ce vaccin sera proposé
je dirais par tranche d'âge il a aussi
tenu à rassurer les français sur la
production de vaccins qui devraient
s'accélérer dans les prochaines semaines
dès fin février début mars nous aurons
des sites qui vont produire le vaccin on
en aura quatre une prise de parole dont
personne n'était au courant et qui
semble avoir été organisée dans la hâte
alors pourquoi le président est il pris
la parole par surprise
et oui pourquoi le président at il pris
la parole par surprise et on vous répond
à 19h49 sur ces vies dans touche pas à
mon poste car on a des réponses on a des
spécialistes ici des spécialistes de
tous et bernard montiel ida là répond
déjà ce que ça vous a étonné à prendre
la réponse de bernard montiel oui barbe
à papa moi ma bulle j'ai du mal à
comprendre sa stratégie de communication
parce qu'il avait bien tué depuis
plusieurs mois les français à donner des
rendez vous à ce que les fonds seraient
nombreux j'aime que son but comme c'est
d'être le plus écouté possible hélas les
audiences a pas particulièrement marché
hier soir mais non téléspectateurs et à
une audience moyenne pour le jt de tf1
c'est la bâillonner que sa part a bien
que oui c'est très bien joué pour maël
ville d'abord est ce qu'ils veulent
elles vivent dimanche à 1 mais c'est
super bien joué pour moi il dit d'abord
c'est moi le chef et il dit aux autres
membres du gouvernement je parle quand
je veux ensuite ils cassent les codes il
le fait par surprise et puis surtout il
vient annoncer une bonne nouvelle donc
je trouve c'est une super stratégie -
vous avez bien vous cette stratégie là
oui à tout mais ça oui d'accord elle est
devenue un sujet bouboule fuscien oui
alors oui eh bien moi j'adore ça
j'adore vraiment savoir ce que je me dis
que justement enfin le président il a
changé de stratégie et en main enfin ils
montrent vraiment qui il est gilles et y
pose ce qu'il faut sur la table ah oui
il prend la parole quand il a envie
parce que moi j'aimerais bien savoir
quand est-ce que les carottes sont
cuites ou pas en tout cas cet analyste
politique c'est à dire 40 les carottes
sont dans le potager j'aurais pas dû
leur dire est qu'elle fait partie du jj
oui oui non si les deux minutes on vous
appelle dans deux minutes allez chercher
vos dalmatiens et bourg envier non
deux minutes il à celle exigée est
certes élevée sont f1 qui est en
audience la plus puissante pour le 20
heures mais comme effectivement comme
l'a dit guillaume ça n'a absolument pas
bougé d'un iota par rapport aux
habituels on peut pas l'accuser d'avoir
fait en sorte que ça soit le plus
d'émotions et jerry est ce que c'est la
question non bachiri qu'est ce qu'on va
robert la caisse monsieur moi je n'ai
entendu dire non mais pourquoi le
président at il pris la parole par
surprise est ce que votre réponse est là
c'est rendu romandie sur un truc a dit
guillaume que je suis noir doit pas pas
dit une connerie et géraldine maillet en
fait il veut montrer qu'il est le boss
montrer que c'est le maître des horloges
il veut montrer qu'il allume enfin mais
c'est qu'ils à swatch mais oui
exactement parce que comme la semaine
dernière il y avait vers ans qui disait
attention attention voilà est cassée
qu'ils aient attention attention donc on
avait tous peur du confinement
il a voulu montrer que c'était lui qui
décide et est encore une fois pour moi
c'est une stratégie politique uniquement
c'est que c'est un tour de cynisme
politique pure et genre c'est moi le
patron
exactement je parle j'ai pas envie de
parler eh ben je me tais radon monterrey
bassiste je savais exactement il clair
nistos football hypo celui-ci s'avère
qu'elle figurait même pas mal mais c'est
le chic anglais ça c'est dur nicolas pas
mal de polémiques quand même autour du
vaccin depuis quelques jours et un
moment donné il voulait juste essayé de
montrer que il connaissait la
problématique du vaccin il est revenu en
arrière pour dire que déjà il ya un an
il avait dit qu'il y aura un accord
européen et que personne mais tu étais
un vrai les droits ou aurait lé droit en
exclusivité pour un pays en l'occurrence
était donald trump est des états unis
il a voulu montrer simple maintenant
stratégiquement je l'aurais pas fait
savoir la lumière était pas belle leçon
était pas bien stress et le résultat il
n'est pas très bon puisque vous savez
bien qu'en général les présidents vont
chercher l'audience parce que le
lendemain ils aiment bien qu'on dise que
l'obédience augmenté de 39 cents dire
donc là pour le coup c'est la minute
c'est normal de la wii alors qu'ils
delphine oui bonsoir je suis un peu
d'accord avec géraldine je pense que
c'est au niveau de son caractère montrer
qu'il est le chef tout simple ça et je
pense que le reste de son équipe n'était
même pas forcément au courant qu'il
allait faire ça donc c'est le président
mais il est totalement hors des cadres
habituels dit bonsoir
non j'ai opérations des jeux s'est bien
passé
ça va ça va de mieux en mieux à mes yeux
tant pas du tout et si ça l'avait sans
rigoler ah ben non on dirait débit mais
non non non non je pense qu'ils avaient
un message important il voulait surtout
dire que le vaccin n'est pas la clé pour
éviter un confinement et ça ouais c'est
ça le problème pour nous annoncer un
confinement voilà je pense aussi qu'il
ay lâcher ça parce qu'il a enfin réuni
tous les patrons de deux labos expliqué
qu enfin je l'ami effectivement c'est
corones sur la table et qu'il a demandé
entre guillemets de réquisitionner les
laboratoires pour produire plus de batz
à la conel la télé mon analyse d'accord
votre analyse franchement elle la mairie
c'est de la merde oui alors on va avoir
les responsables savent à qui ses lacets
bernard noté bernard montiel il a quatre
présidents barbus mais à 90 dont parle
jean bernard mottet est le dit bernard
montiel tu sais qui c'est bernard
montiel aujourd'hui ses 26 années dans
le paf va au chômage de 55 ans et puis
après l'été dans les hôtels d'ici
allongés sur des chaises longues il est
payé à s'asseoir sur tes cheveux c'est
vrai bernard montiel c'est quelqu'un de
respecté au sein du pouvoir
combien conseil des ministres qui c'est
qui ramène le café c'est bernard manciet
comme on l'appelle au conseil des
ministres
gringo mondiale est là bernard mottais
je peux vous dire lui connaît le
président s'y connaît la france fit
alors il dit pas que des conneries parce
que nous quand on passe temps le mans
l'elysée parce que je vous dis quand
vous passez devant l'elysée n'est pas le
droit de passer sur le trottoir de
l'elysée actuellement - jour j'ai voulu
faire le beau gosse j'ai dit c'est quoi
un résident ni kumu je passe sur le
trottoir ludique ce qu'ils vont faire et
je suis passé je partais que les
menottes
ouais les gars direct dans le fourgon a
tenu à lui parce qu'il passe sur le
cahier et comme à lui seul à l'elysée
c'est comme si le soleil va le code du
bouscat non manu c'est moi j'oublie mes
clichés nuit mon frère et rentrer la
voiture et le voiturier tu es prêt j'ai
lancé mon ciel ouais on a toujours la
tête au hockey ce qui s'est passé
d'abord c'est un homme d'abord s'était
pas inscrit dans son agenda présidentiel
vous savez que dans les agendas ont il
ya tout son programme qui est inscrit
que tout le monde peut consulter sur
elysee.fr c'était donc s'il a vraiment
plus consultez l'agenda lui masser comme
son fils jean en a fallu du temps et
emmanuel de matha histoire mais c'est
oui mais pourquoi tu t'es mis en jeans
et un ps le mode de 10 à 12 tu es con
quoi ah oui merde quand il reçoit un
président quand il reçoit des
personnalités ya aucun problème tout ça
est marqué donc c'est vrai que c'était
il a suivi son instinct il a eu envie de
parler pourquoi parce qu'à mon avis à
mon avis non tout était alors s'il vous
plaît arrêtez de dire à votre avis
forissier dédouaner il a l'info sinon
vous ne seriez pas ici marié
tranquillement en train de manger
d'église bête la dtcc des graines de
maïs soulignant je peux vous garantir
qu'il n'était pas au courant très castex
qui est en réunion comme tous les mardis
soirs avec les milices et le premier mis
c'est absolument pas ils ont fait ce
qu'il veut c'est alors justement c'est à
l'issue de cette réunion où il parlait
des vaccins et cetera il a suivi son
instinct parce qu'ils n'avaient eu marre
aussi tâche à nouveau posée sur une
telle question
oui le démarrer bon est-ce qu'il a suivi
son instinct oui il a suivi son instinct
il a cassé les codes c'est pourquoi
c'est pourquoi parce qu'il avait vu marc
toutes ses dernières déclarations qu'il
a faites à la télévision c'était
toujours pour annoncer de mauvaises
nouvelles à ses synthés soit le
confinement ou leur confinement au match
aller vaccins ils voient arriver ils
sont pas là et c'est donc c'est très
compliqué et là en sortant ils étaient
tellement heureux des bonnes nouvelles
qu'il a eu il a voulu les transports
ouais puis là n'a rien à [ __ ] et puis
surtout on en a marre de ce carton de
l'administration on est tous ballotté
par des infos des fausses infos etc
il a eu envie de dire nico book comme
vous dire une nouvelle annonce est belle
et bonne nouvelle les vaccins c'est quoi
les bonnes nouvelles c'est les vaccins
les quatre centres français qui vont
s'ouvrir maintenant pour créer les
vaccins et april may
c'est comme ça c'est une bonne note
j'aurais y chante plus vite à la maison
je dis maman y'a que j'ai eu à 17 mois
quand servir là quand j'avais 1 2 eh ben
je souris chaude et une photocopie je
reconnais qu'à 17 ans fou elle avait
envie de faire un discours positif
d'annoncer ses 4 c'est radical et vous
le savez qu'ils épargnent pas du tout
jure sur la vita moi j'étais j'étais
très occupé hier mais qui n'a pas fait
une belle émission animaux bah ouais
ouais dirais qu'il est sur la chaîne
animaux susi avait des cartons
d'audience à cette dernière il a encore
fait 55 téléspectateurs de labrador
regardez les pensions été surpris mais
56% non 44 % on appelle sondages on peut
passer à autre chose ça ma config
non